at the spot where the terrorists died
police continued their hunt for the
smallest clues detectives aren't looking
for more suspects but they still need to
know exactly how the killer carried out
his deadly attack and why police shot
him dead but the wider question how is
he monitored on his release from white
Moor prison a year ago a government
adviser who did not want to be
identified said funding cuts have led to
community-based mentors being replaced
by civil servants hood is that it will
not be as intense it will be somebody
who's parachuted in from the Home Office
who isn't in his Ventus
who is funded is checked by the Home
Office to work in preventing Channel and
within prisons and so there is a bit of
a disparity between who they are and who
they're you know presenting themselves
as and he may not have reacted as well
to somebody like that what you want is
the interventionist to be somebody who
has the drawer and the pool the charisma
to make him want to be part of his group
so you're replacing one kazamachi
individual with another one
you know ones bad ones good it's not you
know rocket science Khan's presence at
Friday's rehabilitation conference
suggested he was being D radicalized but
at lunchtime there
he murdered an organizer and a volunteer
this photograph was taken in the
conference room 15 minutes before the
attack a witness said it happened on the
floor below this is what the witness
told us there was a piercing scream like
nothing the witness had heard before
everybody who was still in the room at
that point stayed sitting down they were
stunned then a woman walked through the
door she was covered in blood could such
a violent outcome have been avoided by
closer monitoring of calm they will have
looked at the way in which he behaved
his apparent willingness to know to to
accept that that the way he'd acted in
the past not reasonable and so on so I
think there are real difficulties
involved in dealing the somebody who is
as clever as he was at putting up this
mask of good behavior
later police finish their search of the
area
London Bridge was reopened Martin Brunt
Sky News